[Music]
on this sunday night politics the
pandemic and promises the federal
election campaign is underway
it's time to hear your voice why now 17
months after the last one plus how the
tories and ndp plan to win your vote and
why the bloc wants a minority fear and
uncertainty in afghanistan as the
taliban take control again thousands
scramble to get on the last flights out
what will taliban rule look like
canadians helping earthquake ravaged
haiti there's a lot more risk of damage
and destruction and people being trapped
as a result what could hamper the rescue
and recovery and the final days of nova
scotia's tight election race why is the
liberal leader staying out of the
limelight
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
get ready the federal election is
happening the ritz were dropped this
morning justin trudeau triggering
another election two years before he
needs to in the middle of summer and as
parts of this country face a fourth wave
of covet 19. canadians will go to the
polls on september 20th
trudeau calls it a pivotal moment for
canada and just as he was speaking news
broke of a pivotal dangerous moment for
afghanistan the taliban have taken over
the country again these are believed to
be the first pictures of taliban leaders
inside the presidential palace the
afghan president has fled the government
has collapsed the canadian embassy has
suspended operations this is the
entrance to the compound it is deserted
so is the u.s embassy helicopters were
seen airlifting people out the idea
there would be a transition of power has
vanished
kabul airport is chaotic nato says it is
helping to open it and facilitate
evacuations thousands of people
including afghans who worked with
canadian troops are still stranded
desperate for help fearing the taliban
will hunt them and kill them
canada
firmly condemns the escalating violence
and we are heartbroken at the situation
the afghan people find themselves in
today this is especially so
given the sacrifices of canadians who
believe
and continue to believe
in the future of afghanistan
we will continue to work with allies and
the international community to ensure
that those efforts were not in vain
trudeau is promising to bring 20 000
afghan refugees to canada there's been
no detail on how or when an
international crisis unfolding at
exactly the moment trudeau kicks off a
campaign it is a reminder how events can
quickly overtake political strategy and
the big question today is if justin
trudeau is so confident in the strength
and smarts of his government why not
continue with the mandate canadian
voters gave him 17 months ago why call
an election now david aiken has our top
story tonight david well donna that was
the first and second and third thing
justin trudeau was asked this morning
why now and his answer each time was why
not now
so in this
pivotal
consequential moment
who wouldn't want to say
who wouldn't want their chance to help
decide where our country goes from here
the trudeau minority government had been
governing just fine with the support
most often of the ndp and sometimes the
block quebecois
that was not enough apparently for the
liberals this is a moment in which
canadians deserve to have their voices
heard
canadians deserve to make their choices
and like i said i'll leave it for the
others to explain why they don't think
canadians should get to weigh in
in this extraordinarily consequential
historic moment
but the most consequential factor for
liberal strategists are polls polls that
show the liberals with the lead this is
the best chance since 2015 that they
have to actually get a majority again so
you can see what the motivation is the
numbers are there
for them to at least seriously consider
it those strategists may also have
concluded this would be the liberals
only opportunity for months
when would be better when is another
window right
and you know if delta variant is is
starting to creep up
if we know now we've been through it
before it's going to get worse in the
fall so that's not going to be a window
the winter it's certainly not so you
know what i mean like you start to
narrow down your choices and
i think that they would be
crazy not to go
one note on all this john horgan called
a snap election in a pandemic in bc and
he went from minority to majority new
brunswick's blaine higgs did the same
thing a pandemic election went from
minority to majority justin trudeau will
surely be hoping that he will complete
the pandemic electoral hat-trick donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks well
as the campaign began events in
afghanistan unfolded fast the taliban
moved into kabul they're back in charge
20 years after they were driven out in
kabul tonight many are living in fear
especially women and children all
domestic flights have been halted we're
told there are still military flights
operating including by canada justin
trudeau on the first day of his campaign
found himself caught in an international
crisis mercedes stephenson is traveling
with the trudeau campaign
donna a very different scene at the
liberal leaders first campaign stop of
this election campaign in blaineville
quebec a contrast when you hear the
cheers and clapping here to the gunfire
being heard in the streets of
afghanistan tonight a foreign policy
crisis is not how any prime minister
plans to start an election campaign
today justin trudeau saying that he is
heartbroken by the situation in
afghanistan and vowing to continue to
help the afghan people including 20
thousand refugees he has promised to
bring to canada but the liberal leader
was unable to provide a plan for how or
when they would get out while canadian
embassy staff have been evacuated 100
gurkhas approximately have been left
behind nepalese citizens who put their
lives on the line to guard the canadian
embassy they were not approved to be on
the last flight out carrying canadians
which left earlier today
also left behind the interpreters who
worked for the canadian armed forces and
their families thousands of people
sources say in the streets of all ages
vulnerable to the taliban they say they
were told to come to kabul hoping for
evacuation but now they are stranded
without food anywhere to stay or any
security
donna typically foreign policy issues
don't play in elections but with the
sacrifices canada has made in
afghanistan we'll see whether or not
this one is different
all right mercedes stephenson in
blaineville quebec tonight thanks events
in afghanistan as i said moving fast a
little later we'll look at how the
taliban took control and how the u.s is
responding first back to the election
the leader of the official opposition
kicked off his campaign quietly today
aaron o'toole unveiled his campaign
slogan from an empty hotel ballroom his
message secure the future abigail beeman
joins us from the hotel where o'toole is
holding what are called virtual town
halls this afternoon abigail a different
kind of campaign launch
donna this is essentially a tv studio
the conservatives built and have been
using for months now they plan to
continue using it during the campaign
replacing some traditional on the road
campaign events and kicking things off
in a big empty room allowed aaron
o'toole to underline his message
criticizing justin trudeau's election
timing a leader who cared about the best
interests of canadians would be
straining every sinew to secure the
recovery right now
instead
justin trudeau has called an election
whether he wanted a campaign or not it's
only day one and already o'toole is
setting up a wedge issue friday the
liberal government announced mandatory
vaccinations for the federal public
service federally regulated industries
and commercial air rail and cruise
passengers in his first question and
answer session with reporters o'toole
was asked over and over about his
opinions on the government's mandatory
vaccine announcement and on vaccine
passports he didn't give very clear
answers i think we can also have an
approach that uses a whole suite of
health measures from rapid testing and
screening
mask usage to have reasonable
accommodations
for people that may not be vaccinated
whether young children or or or other
people we have to use
all of the tools
and not divide canadians o'toole
completely avoided the question of
whether he requires candidates to be
vaccinated some of his supporters are
opposed to mandatory vaccinations and
he's trying to tread carefully but one
of his challenges this campaign is to
set himself apart from previous leader
andrew scheer to attract more canadians
to his party he's already falling into a
trap that caught sheer evading a
question so reporters are forced to keep
trying to get a clear answer we'll see
if that changes in the days ahead
o'toole defended his decision to have a
campaign kickoff in an empty room by
saying technology allows him to connect
with thousands of voters he's holding
two virtual town halls sunday with
voters in bc and quebec all of this
coveted campaigning is new of course but
we'll have to see whether he can build
traction with less time on the road
fewer chances to meet people in person
for a leader many canadians say they
still don't feel they know
donna all right abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks the ndp leader calls this
election a selfish attempt by justin
trudeau at a power grab drug meat sings
ndp won just 24 seats last time its
worst result in years singh is confident
his party has the campaign war chest and
the right message to make a bigger mark
this time michael couture is on the ndp
campaign
this is the image the ndp wanted while
justin trudeau was in ottawa talking to
candidates
jagmeet singh walked with the people in
montreal's pride parade
singh says sending canadians to the
polls as covid19 cases continue to rise
is a selfish move by the liberal leader
well it's clear justin trudeau wants to
grab power wants a majority but why does
he want a majority
it's certainly not because he wants to
help more people singh's opposition to
the federal election is a stark contrast
to last year when he campaigned with
john horgan in bc helping him convert
his minority government into a majority
singh says trudeau triggered the
election because he's tired of the ndp
pushing them to do better for canadians
people are worried and and they're still
concerned about what this pandemic means
for them their jobs and their in their
future
last week the ndp released a blueprint
for its platform including major policy
planks like universal pharmacare and
dental care something they planned to
pay for with a tax on the ultra rich
hussein is trying to convince canadians
the ndp is the best option after he says
the liberals failed to deliver on some
campaign promises over the last six
years like ending boil water advisories
in all indigenous communities why should
we believe that he's going to deliver
what we ask for now
if he wants to do what people are asking
for let's go back to ottawa and do it
there's no reason why we can't the ndp
admits the 2019 campaign was all about
limiting the number of ridings they
expected to lose but this one couldn't
be more different with better poll
numbers and double the budget compared
to the last election the hope is to add
up to a dozen new seats to the 24 they
already hold donna all right mike
likature in montreal thanks green party
leader anime paul is hoping to make
gains for the greens by getting herself
elected she's still facing an internal
backlash from some in her party who want
her gone paul launched her campaign in
toronto center a rematch in the riding
she lost to a liberal candidate in a
by-election less than four months ago
they underestimate the desire of people
for change that this pandemic has
provoked and we are ready to strike out
in a new direction
paul's leadership has been plagued by
internal conflict but she says her
energy is focused on policies such as
innovation and fighting climate change
and she says the liberals should be
doing the same
the leader of the block quebecois
launched his campaign in montreal today
claiming quebecers have been quite clear
about what they want and don't want
that minority government serves quebec
better quebecers did not want an
election
mr trudeau did
francois blanchette calls trudeau's
decision to call an election
irresponsible and all about personal
gain
what's looming over afghanistan as the
taliban takeover coming up people
scramble to escape as the u.s defends
its decision to leave
[Music]
this is a tense night in afghanistan the
taliban are back in charge after 20
years and the deaths of thousands of
foreign soldiers and afghan civilians
thousands of afghans are now trying to
escape fearing a return to hardline
taliban rule among those watching
anxiously is malala yousafzai who was
shot in the head by a taliban fighter
because she supported girls education
she tweeted today she's deeply worried
about women minorities and human rights
advocates just last month american
president joe biden said a taliban
takeover was not inevitable he was
completely wrong
jennifer johnson reports
this is afghanistan in chaos the
president has fled the country his
government has collapsed and thousands
of afghans are desperately trying to
escape along with western military and
diplomatic personnel
taliban rule is now a reality after
dozens of cities have fallen besieged by
bombings in a campaign of deadly
violence
u.s military helicopters are evacuating
embassy staff members to kabul airport
it may be their only way out with
taliban fighters now encircling kabul
after taking control of most of the
country
it took less than a week after u.s
president joe biden announced he's
pulling american troops out by august
31st
his team blaming afghan security forces
for not protecting its people the
international community invested over
twenty years
billions of dollars in these forces
three hundred thousand of them uh with
an air force unfortunately uh tragically
they have not been able uh to defend the
country a return to brutal taliban rule
is a hellish endgame for people here
women's rights were eliminated under
their control a humanitarian disaster
seems inevitable interpreters and
support workers who've worked alongside
western allies fear they will be killed
if they can't get out they have to take
care about us
it is our turn
to be helped
we help them
weeks ago president biden dismissed
comparisons of this withdrawal to
americans being airlifted out of saigon
during the vietnam war
but many republicans briefed by white
house security advisers see it
differently if you just had president
biden a few days ago saying you wouldn't
see helicopters evacuating the embassy
like saigon and yet here we are this is
this is president biden's saigon moment
and unfortunately it was very
predictable
thousands of taliban and al-qaeda
fighters have been freed from prisons
and concerns about extremism both in
afghanistan and beyond are growing they
are on the verge of having another safe
haven
but this time with all of the
infrastructure and military assets that
we had intended for the afghan
government to use it's terrifying
at the presidential palace in kabul
taliban leaders and former president
hamid karzai are trying to negotiate a
peaceful transfer or sharing of power
but it's clear the peace so many
thousands have died to ensure will not
be realized in afghanistan or for its
people
jennifer johnson global news washington
ahead the aftermath of haiti's
devastating earthquake
rescue efforts are underway tonight in
haiti after a powerful earthquake there
the death toll from the 7.2 magnitude
quake has now soared to almost 1300. at
least 5 700 others are injured and there
are fears both numbers may rise in the
days ahead the canadian assessment team
is on the ground in lakhai the city
hardest hit by the earthquake as heather
urix west explains rescue efforts are
complicated by haiti's tenuous political
situation and an approaching tropical
storm
scenes of devastation in south haiti
saturday's powerful 7.2 magnitude
earthquake leveling areas of lakai
tearing apart roads making access to the
region difficult for those trying to
help
we can say that there are 1500 homes
completely destroyed and 3 000 homes
damaged in the south the country's civil
protection director said sunday
saturday's earthquake was more intense
than the catastrophic magnitude 7 quake
that shook the country in 2010. that
disaster claimed more than 200 thousand
lives displacing more than a million
others the magnitude of the earthquake
was larger than it was in 2010 the area
that's affected is less densely
populated um there's still two major
cities and several towns in the area and
still has a population of around 1.4
million valerie repco and nadia van der
hayden are part of a small canadian
assessment team now on the ground in
lake high global news spoke to them
during a refuelling stopover on route to
haiti on sunday morning right now i can
certainly say
the political environment is very
different than it was in 2010. deepening
poverty the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
and the political turmoil that has
followed the assassination of the
haitian president this summer has
created a very dangerous situation on
the ground
adding to these complications an
advancing tropical storm grace is
forecast to bring heavy rains to the
island nation monday with a risk of
flash floods we're really encouraging
teams to not come down right now this is
not like 2010 the
safety concerns may be different the
security needs may be different and and
we don't want to put everyone at risk
though the situation for thousands of
haitians injured or displaced by yet
another disaster grows more serious by
the day
heather eric's west global news calgary
no guarantees in nova scotia next why
the province's pandemic election is
turning into a nail biter
in politics nothing is ever a sure thing
campaigns really do matter and events
can pop up to derail the front runners
in nova scotia people go to the polls on
tuesday and the incumbent liberals
appear to have a fight on their hands
support for leader ian rankin is
slipping ross lord explains the dynamics
of what could lead to a tense election
night
despite impacts on canadians ranging
from stressful to devastating covert 19
has boosted the popularity of
governments in five pandemic elections
no province or territory has chosen to
vote out a governing party nova scotia
liberal leader ian rankin hopes the
streak doesn't end with him we've made
some significant investments in ten
dollar a day child care and some other
programs investing in housing investing
in the programs that people need as we
recover from the pandemic but the
liberals are making a peculiar
investment in rankin's political
fortunes in the closing days of the
campaign when parties normally crank up
their leader's media exposure rankin has
largely stayed out of the spotlight
no i don't i don't know why there are no
media events i'm not sure that i don't
understand that question the liberals
entered the campaign riding a wave of
popularity for managing covert 19. but
public opinion polling suggests there's
been a shift with both the pcs and ndp
gaining ground i think this is a really
difficult one to predict and and i would
not have said that a month ago so i
think the liberals entered this race in
such a strong position that it it
it was almost a given and this suggests
that's not the case polling suggests
one-third of nova scotia voters were
still undecided in the campaign's final
week as the pcs and ndp continue
hammering what they say is the liberal's
poor overall management of health care
and housing the message that i want nova
scotians to receive is we will work with
your community we will listen to you we
will respect you and we will make sure
you have access to health care we are
going to bring in permanent rent control
and we are we are going to establish a
network of same-day next day walk-in and
mental health clinics interest in the
outcome goes far beyond people in the
province now that justin trudeau's
liberals have decided to force a federal
election the fate of nova scotia
liberals becomes even more intriguing
ross lord global news halifax
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this postcard perfect shot of
stratford ontario thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you